c'est ça chaque bassin dit que l'arrière
[Applaudissements]
quelques stars pour votre anniversaire
mais musulman je n'ai pas être invitée
hier soir mercredi et le vendredi
comment il vendredi bah oui mais c'était
hier soir votre anniversaire je pensais
que j'avais une soirée donc je me suis
habillé pour l'aquarelle je reste à
venir il ya très peu de soirée que tu
m'as déjà un petit cadeau quand même à
manille je suis l'indiquent qui pique
ton coeur bat s'adorent ouais ouais
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour la table de chevet savais pas
ce que je voulais dire un truc c'est que
sacha il venait me voir à la radio sur
virgin radio c'est très souvent le matin
il restait avec moi voilà il voulait
vraiment faire ce métier donc pour vous
dire c'est un passionné il venait il se
réveiller très tôt est resté de six
heures jusqu'à 9h écouter l'émission est
vrai que c'est vraiment un bon
anniversaire
mais cyril c'est pas parce que là que
j'arrive que ça va être votre fête la
note versée maintenant mais d'abord ce
soir je m'explique je risque marc
carrière alors je suis arrivé qu'un
petit truc pignon pour rendre
l'atmosphère sympathique mais ce soir je
prend de gros risques puisque c'est un
indic spécial baba mais d'abord on
commence par les bonnes habitudes c'est
la séquence tout ce qui se passe pendant
les offenses et maintenant dans les pubs
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] de luz et sa coach ball
inside
l'adversaire luz et 50 secondes side de
pmp on commence tout de suite avec un
baba très sexy dès cette semaine comme
d'hab
les chiens ne font pas des chats dans la
famille hanouna le business c'est dans
la peau tu fais payer 1 3 balles fait
payer trois balles 3 5 balles
justement on a bien il ya un vrai souci
cette année
c'est l'argent qui nous donne tu veux le
récupérer là
votre vie que l'homme sait encore moins
draguer que gilles verdez d'un monde
bien sûr non c'est un rhume c'est
pourquoi c'est le chat la chaleur la
fraîcheur d'un koh pich dort à poings
sur le lit en plus l'histoire family
business épisode 2 décidément ils sont
forts chez la luna
l'annoncé a que deux il se crée tout ça
n'est que de
démissionner
j'ai retour jean michel maire une chose
est sûre il n'a pas changé
tu l'as fait une fois pas deux non pas
toi nous
et le nrj music awards lèche ou boule de
la semaine est attribué à mathieu
delormeau fera pas comme les autres tu
partiras tu me tues tu m'oublieras
jamais séparé guillaume genton son
meilleur ami après l'échauffement
discours à mayol je suis ce que vous
avez même éventuellement faire tourner
des mers votre agglomération dit par
chez
moi ça semaine dernière
[Musique]
et attention scoop on va perdre nicolas
pas les coptes qui élèvent élevé les
cochons t'étais pas là steendam
lestat classique on finit avec le
conseil de la semaine signée bat sara
toi tu te lave les mains ouais ça me
tall avait le cul
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
oui c'est extraordinaire mais ça mais
c'est exact cette détresse
je voulais proby ça va être votre fête
puisque c'était votre anniversaire hier
soir et hier la dir est un personnage
qui nous offre une pièce de théâtre à
chaque fois qu'il vient chaque semaine
sur ce plateau c'est fabrice di vizio
évidemment sauf que plus le temps passe
cyril plus j'ai l'impression que vous
lâcher complètement la rampe pendant les
interviews de fabrice di vizio alors à
la maison vous voyez le sketch et de
fabrice division mais vous voyez pas
forcément l'hôte sketch qui se passe en
syrie regardez bien ces réactions c'est
le ba-ba comedy club
sur fabrice di vizio il y en a qui ont
eu le sentiment qui s'est servi des pmp
pour arriver à défendre et en politique
parce que vous c'est votre sentiment au
pas mais on n'a pas le sentiment comme
de prendre un peu le melon là alors moi
j'ai jamais alors moi j'ai pas le ballon
je déteste ce fruit mais vous êtes un
pitre médiatique vous êtes un moulin à
vent
le producteur maintenant que tout le
monde c'était tester non ok ça ne marche
pas
tu as cool ça va mais j'ai souvent des
cadres historiques remplir mes fans ans
vous saviez très bien je ne pouvais pas
que le public là ils ont tous et un
masque et un pass and i ter à la tune
est responsable de rien ça me tuerait
fonctionne de vous avoir cru ah oui
ouais mais tu crois
pas du tout j'adore l'hépatite mois
fabrice jeay c'est à dire que moi j'ai
jamais
facile fabrice
assieds-toi point quel point tu apprends
que
j'avais actuellement à mon ami fabrice
tu veux un petit tout choco tu m'as une
citronnade avec un boy scout ou sûr je
passe pourquoi moi tu passes pour
quelqu'un de cool
de fermer saab et hawtai tempo comme
mckinsey à la limite parce que moi tpm
belhadj et personnes là qui de mckinsey
mathew tait et laisse tomber
je veux partir je mentais c'est tout tu
vois on ne sait pas trop je vais chez
moi tu vas pas une chicha parce que
on a dû tout petit navire
[Applaudissements]
ont serré continuer à ces circontances
que tu aimes bien comme ça mais en fait
tu me rappelles nouvelle il ya plus
d'intérêt tout ce que fait l'iran n'en
fais pas ça ne me le dire n'importe quoi
mais ça la kingston
oui c'est ça oui c'est un chaos
incroyable magnifique 3 châu favori
une séquence qui cartonne dans touche
pas à mon poste c'est revue pas vu mais
on n'a jamais fait de vue pas vu spécial
baba alors bien pas vu ça fait quand
même huit ans qu'on l'a pas fait
ces problématiques on avait sur wii où
j'ai l'impression que les motifs sur ben
il ya le fut pas vu spécial baba parce
que souvent dans l'émission les
collecteurs débattent sur les émissions
du paf top chef danse avec les stars etc
mais donc les chroniqueurs donnent leur
avis et parfois de cyril aussi bien
votre avis est ce que ce petit animal
dit pareil pendant les magnétos ou là et
la langue
avec beaucoup de vérifications après
beaucoup de nettoyer le magnéto
la nettoyer l'eau mais neto on vous a
gardé le meilleur c'est cyril baba le
tabac ça me dérange pas du
bon vous avez un petit récap donc de
danse avec les stars qui a bien marché
vendredi c'était enfin le retour de
danse avec les stars sur tf1 danse avec
les stars tiens je vais là-bas je les
palais
je vais là-bas je les balaye est aussi
le danseur francs soit lui qui donne
pleins de conseils quatre ans soit les
frères et c'est pas du papier ce matin
[Musique]
franchement je sais pas comment on peut
faire pour regarder danse avec les stars
je m'en bas tellement les couilles de
[Musique]
sai père intéressant de voir des stars
comment il se comporte vraiment quand
elle a la garde le bon dieu de la danse
mais c'est vrai aujourd'hui vous prend
la même personne on retire 75 kg et
naples en bas je suis là aucun voilà peu
coup sur ton
c'est là beaucoup qui valsent jo
vas-y mais ferme ta gueule
[Applaudissements]
ce sont bien eux
jamais adolescents les jeunes dogues
[Musique]
y a vraiment décidé de pas fermer sa
gueule
[Musique]
si abbas y est franchement moi je m'en
bats les 12
moi j'adore
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'était un jeu avec eux
aussi marie ce soir là mais du coup the
void ans avec l'agenda j'aime bien là il
avait l'air sympa il est bourré après
c'est vrai de vrai je le dis ça ne sera
pas cédé très bonne émission dont il a
tu laisses tu as raison mais je m'en
bats les fêtes mais vraiment ça ne
m'intéresse pas du tout c'est très bien
mais vraiment que ça ne m'intéresse pas
du tout c'est ça va ça m'en touche une
sans faire bouger l'autre
c'est vrai cheryl avant de repartir jeu
on va pas se mentir ici autour de la
table dit la vérité on adore on aime
bien on vous suit comme ça c'est des
très bas émission mais vous en soirée
non mais moi si on peut être public mais
ils sont karine q
c'est pas parce qu'on regarde on peut
regarder quelque chose mais sankara cuba
il ya plein de choses que je regarde si
on perd le cul non mais là comme ça il
ya plein de choses toit par exemple
sont de très belles émissions mais c'est
vrai que je franchement je m'en fout
totalement de savoir qui va gagner dans
ces questions qui va gagner sauvage
franchement ça va pas changer mon bas
voilà ma ligne
et le dia chaque fois même voilà que pg
gagne marseille gagne truc oui ça peut
changer ma vie parce que je fais un
kiffe mais que quelqu'un qui vienne the
boys qui est ici sans apporter moi qui
sont la suite
ah oui tiens elle avant de repartir ils
rêvaient a pris goût non ça va changer
dans votre vie rien ben alors fermez la
c'est vrai que je m'en tape complètement
moi c'était mon seul plaisir de plus
être lassé de plus être obligé de
regarder deux journaux mais
c'est les peurs ses missions mais là on
tombe devant on regarde mais après ça on
voit la même chose c'est pourri chine
s'appuie non mais non on est pas content
le format marche très fort oui bien sûr
et kelly
ouais je m'en fous merci mais ça crée
des nouvelles personnes sauf que le
gagnant dans cet état où le gagnant de
the voice ça devient
même surtout quand même sorti kenji mais
km les premières sorties
le guen
allez
danse avec les stars alors que tout le
monde s'en bat les couilles on l'a vu
dans le magnéto
avant de repartir une petite mignonne
riz j'ai eu la chance en exclusivité
d'interviewer le prochain présentateur
de touche pas à mon poste mais qui n'est
autre que lino hanouna non le fils celui
qui est à côté de moi oui alors je vais
demander qui y voyaient pour vous
remplacer alors déjà je vous dis il m'a
répondu lui d'accord je vais il se voit
prendre votre place dans quelques années
sauf que il encore un peu jeune je
comprends il encore mais dans deux ans
il a le même niveau que moi
il a 9 ans à 11 ans il est prêt il est
encore un peu jeune donc du coup je vais
demander ce qu'ils pensaient des
chroniqueurs et qu'ils étaient aptes à
vous remplacer diana dire cyril tel père
tel fils
[Musique]
on dit moi qui le connais car tu
aimerais voir la passe de ton perdre des
pmp lassalvy
elle dit et du coup mon tienne il est
roi lear il est trop bien monté
c'est qu'ils agissent label 90 jours
maxime béland de l'ordre présentés tpp
passe de ton père mimine gilles verdez
ait fini trop vieux trop bien aussi
[Applaudissements]
si mais
entendre
alors je vous dis il avait l'air très
honnête
julio silva le sens des affaires selma
vende un bounty 10 euros et elle sait
c'est pour avoir un bon petit 0 c'est le
prix aujourd'hui
bon à la famille entre les six fours
merci ça le salomé adobuzz
[Applaudissements]